項目をつ取っちゃえば
取ってみれば前の項目を消すものになっちゃうんです
例えば生 生まれることと老死で考えちゃえば
現れる生まれる機能現れたんだから
憎しみ 苦しみ 悲しみが生まれるでしょ
今何か現れたんだから苦しみが生まれる
例えば人が死んだという現象が現れるんですね
それ生なんです そこで悲しみが次に
生まれてくるんですね
その項目つだけ取っちゃえば
苦しみなければ生を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
それで有とジャータの場合は有と生の場合は生が嫌だったら有を消すんですね
そこで執着と有の場合は
やっぱり執着の方を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで まあこのお釈迦様もいろいろ軽々と説明説法はしているんだけど
その中にものすごいこの理解しにくいほど複雑な考え方があるんです
だからもう一遍聞いただけではまあ理解できるものでもないんです
だからご自分で考えるしか方法ないんです
そこで 例えば今私たちは人間として現れているんだから
今私たちの問題は 私たちの本当の私たちの問題は
まあ年取るは病気になるは
いろんな苦しみ 憎しみ
悲しみ生まれてくるは
だから苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
それは遠い昔の無明だからと
言うと その原因は消せないんですね
過去だから 遠い昔が無明があって
それから行が生じて それからどんどんどんどん現在私がここにいるんだと言うと
現在私の苦しみ 悩みに対してもうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば原因は遠い昔のことだから
今更どうすることもできないでしょうし
だから四苦諦でその問題は取ってはいけないことなんです
アビダンマでは四苦諦を説明しています
それで今私に年取ること
病気になること 苦しみ
悲しみが今ある ということは
今私に無明があるんですね
今も 今も無明から生じる行があるんです
今も行から生じる識があるんです
今も識から生じる名色があるんです
全部ここにいっぺんにあるんですね
だから このいっぺんに今の体にある無明か渇愛かどっちか上の方何か一つ取ってしまえば
問題が終わっちゃうんです
そこでそのリストを見ると
なんでそういうリスト作ったかって
リストをよく見ると なんか取れるもの
簡単に取れるものを見つかるんです
そういうわけで そのすごい不可思議なリストできているんです
例えば六処 サラヤタの処を見てください
サラヤタの処 六処でしょ
あれは六処というのは眼耳鼻舌身ですね
眼耳鼻舌身取ってやろうと思っても無理でしょうに
目と耳鼻などを取ってやろうと
それは無理 それで解脱を得られるんだと
でも論理的には得られるんです
目と耳鼻とか その六処をきれいさっぱり消してしまえば
すべて消えるんです それは論理的なんです
生まれないんだから もう何も
それで識もないんだから
でもそれ無理ですね で
それから六処にいろんな物事を触れるでしょ
触れることによって どんどんどんどんウェーダナーやラーグ
ジューやラーグ カッサヤから生まれてくるし
我々のいくらか触れることコントロールできるんですね
触れることのコントロールできる
目にはいろんなものを見えてくると苦しみが生まれてくるんだったら
見えるものをコントロールしてしまえば
いくらか苦しみが減るでしょうに
耳で聞いて いろんなことで我々は悩んだり苦しんだりするんだから
じゃあ聞くものを抑えておくと
いくらかはコントロールできるんだけど
だからといって一切目にものを触れないようにするということは不可能であるし
一切耳に何も触れないようにするということは不可能であるし
やっぱり例えばもう社会から離れて
人から離れて 自分一人で一番寂寥なところで
何も見るものがないところでいたら
その分心の苦しみがなくなる
全ての情報をカットしちゃうと
もうかなり苦しみがなくなりますよ
例えば自分の誰かが親戚誰かが死んで死にましたよと電話でも入ってきたら情報入るでしょうに
耳から それで苦しみが生まれてくるでしょうに
電話もテレビもラジオも何もない場合は
人が死のうが生まれてこようが自分には関係ないことなんですね
世の中どうなっているか自分がわかりませんからね
それで楽にいられるんですけどね
じゃあそれで全ては楽が得られるかというとそうでもないんですね
それでも目に耳に物事を触れてるんだからね
そういう風にこの項目を見ると
コントロールできるものできないものということを見出せることはできますね
そこでファッサの無理なんですね
コントロールできますけど
無理 全て消すことは無理
ですから いくらかファッサコントロールできると
いくらかウェーダナーのコントロールもできます
ウェーダナーというのは感じることだから
だから触れると同時に感じてしまうんですね
それもコントロールできないもので
じゃあ感じるものを感じると同時にカッサイが生まれるでしょうに
いとも簡単にそこら辺でコントロールできる
割愛さえ作って作らないようにしておけばシステムが壊れるんですね
ですから このカツアイというタンハというものは大事なポイントで
原因としてで考えている
で カツアイでもよろしいし
ウパーダーの執着でもよろしいんですね
カツアイから執着生まれるんだから
でもカツアイ消せばいいし
それが一番上の項目 無明
無明を見ると無明だから明が生じるんだから
だから無明をなくせば
まあ問題は終わりでしょうということです
無明とは何ですかというと
やっぱりこの物事の本当の姿を知ってない状態だから
じゃあ物事の本当の姿を知っておけば大丈夫と
ということで 知ることで全てなくなっちゃいますということで
知恵の教えになってしまっちゃうんですね
知恵で終わりと 知恵が入れた途端
アヴィッジャーの代わりに知恵が入っちゃうんですね
そうすると行が生まれ
生まれなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 最終的に解脱ということを目指す人が無明をなくすことに努力するか
渇愛をなくすことに努力するか
どっちかで頑張ればいいんですね
だから全て今もあります
もも も今あるんですね
その中で で 一つだけ取ってもらおうと努力する
渇愛か無明かどっちか
そういう説明は初期経典の説明で
で 初期経典の学問的な論文とかは膨大な量ありますけど
その説明はどこにもないんです
ですからまあ気をつけて聞いた方がいいんです
まああの一応わかりにくくなるっていうのもアヴィッジャって何でしょうかと
特別な項目として見ようとすると
わかりにくくなるんですね
だからそれはちょっとした働きとして見ればいいんです
アヴィッジャっていうのは
お釈迦様の説明っていうのは
空・渋・滅・道を知らないことだと
すごく簡単に説明しているんですね
一切は苦であることわからないでしょうと
だからわからないでしょうに
ただそれだけのこと 一切は苦であることわからないんだから
サンカーラ 行っていうのはなんとなく何かしようというエネルギーなんです
で 何かしようという気持ちになってくるし
何かしようと思うのはヴィンニャーナで識だから
心だからね だから心があって
心はもうなんかイライラ状態になって
ちょっと振動を起こしちゃうんですね
振動を起こしちゃうのは
もう全てはドゥッカであるということがわからないんだからなんですね
そこで振動を起こすことはサンカーラと呼ぶんです
そこで振動自体は識なんですね
心は瞬間瞬間振動していることは心というんですね
だから離れないんです
行と識が そこで心が心がもうイライラ状態になる
イライラというよりは
なんとなく不安定な状態になる
なんとかせねばという状態になる
我々にそれは簡単にわかりますでしょうに
何か見なくちゃ 聞かなくちゃ
食べなくちゃとか いつでもあるでしょうに
何かしなくちゃという気持ちが
それは行なんです それほど難しいことでもないんです
座ってるとやっぱり立たなくちゃということになるし
立ってると座らなくちゃってことになっちゃうし
何をしても次に何かしなくちゃと
これではダメという気持ちが生まれてくるんです
ご飯食べてる時もいろいろ味のものなんで揃ってるかというと
だから人の言葉は全部いい加減
例えばもう食べると場合は
例えば５種類の品物を揃っていると
そこでそこで納豆もあるとする
その人の中で納豆はどうですかと
美味しい これはすごく美味しいですよと
それ美味しいです それだけ食べなさいということは論理的なんですけど
納豆も食べながら味噌汁も飲んじゃうでしょう
で またご飯も食べるでしょう
ご飯の味はどう？ご飯美味しいですって言うんですね
ああいう美味しいであればいい加減です
人間の言葉っていうのは
ご飯も美味しいんだったらなんで他のもの食べるんですかね
だから味噌汁飲んでも
あ これでは飽きませんと
他の何か味わわなくちゃという気持ちが生まれるんです
納豆食べる時でも それではダメということがそこにあるんで
だから美味しいですというのは嘘です
美味しいんだったらそれだけ食べればいいんですけど
そういうことで 味に酔ったっても
味を 味を変えなくちゃ
変えなくちゃ 他の味を味わわなくちゃというサンカーラがずっと働いてるんですね
それでたくさん品物を食べる時は作らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
それで物事は終わることじゃなくて
昼は食べた 何か食べたならば
夜はまた違うもの またなっちゃうでしょうね
そちらにも行が働いてるんですね
なんでそういうのやるかというと
無明だからなんですね
それ何やっても無意味だと
終わりがないんだと 結局結果は同じでしょうと不安で終わっちゃうでしょうに
不満で終わっちゃうでしょうに
朝何か食べて 昼何か食べて
夜何か食べて それで完璧かと
完璧じゃないんです 次の朝はまた違うものを食べようとしているんだから
それどこまで続くんですかと
どこまで続いたっても同じ結果なんですね
不満で終わると ああ 不満で終わるんだという智慧がないんですね
だからドゥッカが知らない
だから無明あるんですね
ですから 無明やらサンカーラ
行というものが我々にわからない
わからない 隠れているものではないんです
日常生活の中で明確に体験しているものなんです
だから無意味だということは頭に全然浮かばないんですね
その代わりに まあ頭だけに浮かんだとしても
それは本物じゃないんだからね
美味しいですよという言葉と同じく本物じゃないんだから
口先でやっぱり無意味だというふうにね
いくらスポーツやってもやっぱり年取るんだ
無意味だと言うんだけど
心の中でやっぱり頑張りますという気持ちがあるんだからね
人はみんな病気になるんだということは口先で言うんだけど
やっぱり病気にならないように頑張らなくちゃということがあるでしょう
だからもう全て嘘で固まってるんです
全て生命っていうのは
まあ簡単に嘘の塊でありますから
だからそれは仏教はまあ愚か者という言葉で平気で使っているんですね
だから真理の人っていうのは悟った人だけ
悟った人 悟ってない人は真理の人じゃないんですね
真理 考えたりも喋ったりもしませんから
で それであの心ヴィンヤーナ
識 識がもうなんとなくイライラ状態みたいな不安定な状態になってくる
それで名色が生れるんだと
名色っていうのはまた心と体のことなんですからね
それによって心と体の働きが生れるでしょうに
例えば まあ朝はパン食べたんだから
昼はじゃああの何でしたっけ？じゃあそばにしましょうということになるで
それについて体が動かさなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それについて体を動かさなくちゃいけないし
それでそばという物質も生まれてくるし
例えば座っていて ああ疲れたという感じが生まれる
それは行なんです 同時に
なぜならば変化しなくちゃというイライラ状態生まれるんだから
それで触っていうこと生まれるでしょうに
だから座ってる体と体が触る体になるんです
そこで体が変わるんです
体がエネルギーの塊で見るならば
完璧にエネルギー変わるでしょう
だから我々は必ず新しい体と言うんです
それは一般の人には理解できない
別に新しい体じゃない
同じ私が立ったんだと思ってる
それは嘘です 言葉の世界だから
で 嘘と理解できる方法はあるんです
例えばラジオに電気入れておこう
電気入れておいたら電気がスピーカーから出てくるでしょう
じゃあスピーカーから電気が出てきますかね
出てくるのは音でしょ
だから音と電気が全く別質なものでしょ
なぜ別質かというとエネルギーですから
電気もエネルギーであって音もエネルギーなんです
そこで体自体がエネルギーで見ちゃうと
座ってる体と立ってる体は全く別質なものであるはずなんです
そこで立ってる人にも心がある
立たせているんだから
立ってるんだから 心がなければ立てませんだから
ですから立ちたいなという業が生まれたら
立ってる認識が生まれてくるんです
だからすごくそんなに隠れてる事実ではないんです
明確な もう鼻の前先にある事実なんです
そこで何かしなくちゃいけないと思ったところで体が変わるでしょうし
それでその人はどのように行動するかというと
眼耳鼻舌身で行動しなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それで物に触れなくちゃいけないでしょうね
触れたらそこで感じるでしょうね
感じたものについて そこで欲を作るでしょうね
そこでそれにとらわれて
新しい状態がまた生まれる
お腹が空いたら 次にご飯作って食べて満腹状態が作る
そちらにこの十二因縁も働いています
一つ残らず全て だから常にいつでもこの十二因縁という機能が我々の体の中で働いています
まあそれまあまあまあ理解ちょっと難しいかもしれませんけど
初期仏教の考え方 それからこの
順番の説明に行くとどうなるか
順番というのはもう卵が原因でヒヨコが結果という順番ですね
だから決してヒヨコが後
先にいて 卵は後ということはないんです
順番だから 花は先にいて
それ消えると実が現れてくる
それは順番 米が先にあって
次にご飯が現れる ご飯から米が現れてこない
この一方的に時間の軸で流れていくんですね
一方 何て言いますか 一方方向で流れていくんです
それはシーケンシャルという意味なんですね
でもそちらにある すごい欠点がシーケンシャル的な出来事は確実に世の中であるんです
でもそれは教えて押し通っちゃうとどうしようもないってことになっちゃうんです
例えば生まれたヒヨコに何か欠陥があると
それは卵の中で欠陥があったんだからでしょう
だから今更どうやって卵の方を変化できますかね
卵を産んだニワトリが何か悪いものを食べたとかね
何かあったということで
卵に中に欠陥があって
あるいは卵が温めてる時点で何か起きたとする
それでヒヨコの体に欠陥がある
何かできますかね それだったらもう何もできませんね
もう一旦ヒヨコが生まれちゃったら
もう卵はもうそこにないんだから
時間を逆に回してもらって
また卵の状態になってもらって
それは不可能ですね シークエンシャルに取ることのその問題があるんです
そうすると宗教じゃなくなっちゃうんです
定めになっちゃうんです
運命になってしまっちゃうんです
お手上げ状態になっちゃう
そうなるんですけど 人間にはそれしか理解できないんだから
理解の世界です だからまあどうしようもない
いくら因果法則勉強したってても
頭に入ってるのはシークエンシャルの法則だけ
だからいくら勉強したっててもそれじゃないとということを言わなくちゃいけないんですね
じゃあそれじゃないと私はもっと勉強してみますと
やってるでしょうに それで私たちに言えるのは
いえ それじゃないと 頭の中にはこのシークエンシャルでいつでも入っちゃうんです
そういうわけで 仏教の世界では一番難しい教えは因果法則なんです
それと面白いことは 仏教の基本を知らないうちに
私に因果法則について喋ってくださいと偉そうに言うんだから
私も今日何回も喋りましたけどね
そこで結果として私が間違ってるんだという結果になるんです
私もわざと きちんと理解できないように喋ります
だからきちんと理解したらそれほど危ないことはないんだから
その理解自体が間違ってるんだから
だからなんだかちょっと難しくてわからない状態ではいいんです
そのだから知識としてはこの理解は足らないということでずっとあった方が
まあいつか頑張ってちゃんと理解するだろうということで
そんなに明確にきちんと喋ることができるならば
今さら頭の悪い私の前に先に
お釈迦様はそれおっしゃっておくでしょうに
お釈迦様はさ やってないことはね
それはもう大乗仏教の影響なんですね
完全に間違っているのに
問題をね 間違って取っているのにも
それで因果法則をバカにしているでしょう
それは小乗の教えだと
空は大乗の教えだと この教え自体ももう変変な変ですからね
色即是空 空即是色と言ってるんだからね
幼稚園の子供だったらそれぐらいの間違いはしたっても構いませんだけどね
そこに基づいて基づいて
因果法則はそんなことはないんだ
だって現に我々の生きている世界でもあるものです
ある法則ですからね  そういう話を置いておいて
次のポイントに行きます
アビダンマから見ればアビ
っていうのはある心素で
あの毛髪という心素ですね
いわゆる無知という痴という心素であって
サンカーラの場合はまあいろいろあるんだけど
アビダンマで取っているのはこの意思
チェータナという心素ですね
ヴィンヤーナはもう心ですね
ナーマ・ルーパの場合はまた色と心と
その二つ取っていて サラーヤタは原理主義システムにしておいて
カッサは俗という心素なんですね
ウェーダナーは受という一行の心素なんですね
タンハーは欲という心素ですね
で でもそういう心素の説明でも混乱しますけどもね
本当は まあそういうことで
まあルーパーは何でしたっけ
自分の場合はバグっちゃいます
ともかく カーンバ・ヴァッタ・ヴァーラという四つありますから
四つありますから ヴィッサン
サッサーナ 結局それも合致はいいだと思いますけど
バヴァはまたこれサンカーラと似ているんです
意識です で ジャーティは生まれることで
まあそういう説明なんです
じゃあ次にこのアッデ
時間の問題に行きます
時間の場合はこのアヴィッジャーとサンカーラがあのアティータっていうんですね
アティータっていうのはpastですから過去なんですね
過去生 そこでアヴィッジャーとサンカーラから過去生を作るんです
まあ過去生というより過去の生
生ですね 過去の生まれ
過去の人生 そこでヴィンヤーナというのは今生で生まれるんだと
生まれる心 正気心というアビダンマで説明してやったんだから
結晶心 正気心というより結晶心ですね
そこで結晶して それから体が出てきて
それから六処が出てきて
そうこうこうやってウパーダのバヴァまで行くんですね
このバヴァまでのところはヴァッタマーナ
パーリ語ではヴァッタマーナというんですけど
今ですね 現在 現在の我々の生まれ
あのテキストではパッチュッパッナという言葉かな
パッチュッパッナっていうのも現在っていう意味ですね
そこで ここで最後のジャーティっていうのは来世
穴開け まあ大体まあこれであの三世にこの流れ
本当は今の瞬間に十二もあります
ありますけど アビダンマではそこで伸ばしてもう三世にしているんですね
過去もあって現在もあって将来もあると
そこでアビダンマ世界ではここで何を頑張るしているかというと
やっぱり輪廻という そういうわけで終わりませんということを
一応三世に分ける場合はこれぐらいでよろしいんです
過去でアヴィッジャあって無明があって
そこでもういっぱいサンカーラが生まれる
そういうわけで サンカーラの場合は業で取ってるんですね
無明だから業を作るんだと
カルマ カルマ作るんだと
このカルマのせいで新しい現在で生まれてしまったと
ヴィンニャーナが 決勝心が生まれてしまったと
それで体が成長するでしょう
それで現在も我々には渇愛やら固執やらありますから
執着があるんだから また現在でもカルマを作るんだと
ババというのはカルマなんです
人が現在でもいっぱい業を作るんだと
それでその業によって来世でまた生まれるんだと
業の結果 また生まれたら
また生老病死 苦しみ 悲しみ
悩みなどなど また生まれる
そういうわけで終わらないんだ
だから じゃあそこで別にお釈迦様の教えから脱却しているわけでもないんだけど
こういうふうにシークエンシャル的にお釈迦様は教えてないだけのことで
だからこの場合も 例えば修行する場合は
その人は現在のことを修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
過去の無明は放っておいた方がいいんです
過去の業 カルマも放っておいた方がいいんです
もうどうしようもないから
でも今 業を作らないならば
もう来世がなくなっちゃうでしょうし
ですから 現在と来世のつながりがありますから
じゃあ来世が生まれないようにもう頑張ればよろしいんですから
まあですから 仏教の道から別に脱出しているわけじゃないんです
そのシーケンシャル説明からでも
ただ 輪廻を説明しようではないか
人が死んだだけで全て終わったというわけじゃないんだと
今もすごいエネルギーを持っているんではないか
エネルギーを持ってやりたいことをいっぱいありのままで死んじゃえば
次になんとかまたなるということ
やりたいことが何もない状態で死ななくちゃいけない
[背景の雑音]まあそれだけで
それからこの次にこの七番目
安賀とかと四十二があるんだと書いてますね
それはもう説明しましたからね
この十二なんですね アビッチャー
サンカー ヴィンヤーナ
ナーマルーパそれはまあそれで十分です
そこでこの二百四十ページのアーカーラサンビサンケータという三つ
行相の二十 連結の三と五取
五取四と 五取四 この行相二十っていうのは十二の四をまあ二重に増えることなんですね
よく考えると二重ではないか
こういうこと 例えば過去生で無明があるんだと
で 無明から行 生まれるということは
過去生にもこの人には
この人にヴィンヤーナがあったし
体もありましたし それで六処もありますし
ありましたし それで触れることもありましたし
そこで触れることによって感覚もありましたし
感覚から渇愛も生まれるし
渇愛から執着も生まれるんですね
執着からまた業を作ったりもしますね
そこでこちら八あるでしょうし
だから上の二つにこの八も入っちゃうんです
わかりますね それ難しくないんです
例えば私が過去生でいたというと
過去生で無明があったと
行があった それだけあったわけじゃないでしょうに
過去生でもいたんだから
やっぱり体もあって色もあって
六処もあって そこで執着があって
そこで業もあって いろんな業までありました
ということで こちらにこの八を足しちゃえば十になっちゃいますね
この上の八を足しちゃうんですね
下の八 それで過去に十あるようになります
そこで現在の問題考えてみると
現在生まれてる私にはヴィンヤーナがあります
ナーマルーパもあります
サラーヤタナもあります
ファッサ ヴェーダナー
タンハー ウパーダナ バヴァまでありますね
ということは 今の私には無明も行もあるということなんですね
に足しちゃう そこで二重になっちゃうんですね
[咳]